[Musique]
c'est un grand honneur parce que les
beatles y était allé vous n'y connaissez
rien aux bébés qui ça eleanor rigby
annoncé un connaît pour sa marine
tatata piano sur marine c'est idiot
c'est très amusant
[Musique]
si vous démissionnez ce sera pris comme
un véritable affront autre façon de
vivre est un affront aux fonctions sont
un an avant vous n'aimez pas mes
chaussures vous ne voyez plus faisant
plus partie intégrante de ce monde
le plus difficile dans tout ça c'est
d'écouter d'entendre sa voix la voix du
seigneur
m
pas moi qui ai besoin d'être satisfait
c'est un milliard deux cents millions de
croyants
vous savez il ya un dicton dieu pluie
toujours un pape en offrant au monde son
successeur j'aimerais que ma punition
arrive
[Musique]